this is the aftermath of the latest
attack against chile's multi-billion
dollar forestry industry by an
indigenous mapuche rebel group in the
south central part of the country
congress's approval of the government's
request for yet another extension of a
state of emergency in the araucania
region wasn't surprising
but it's come with a high dose of
ridicule against left-wing president
gabriel boric
the same people who are highly placed in
government today and who not only
attacked the previous government
strategy but voted against all the
extensions of a state of emergency last
year have the nerve to come here to ask
us for the fourth time to approve the
same measure
conservatives voted in favor of allowing
the army to patrol alongside militarized
police in the rest of region
but several left-wing deputies from
porichi's own coalition especially the
communist party voted against the
measure
they accused the president of betraying
his electoral promise to promote
dialogue and not use force
earlier the spokesman of cam the oldest
mapuche resistance group took
responsibility for the new attack
our priority is to channel violence
towards well-directed acts of sabotage
towards supplies and machinery
the government said it would not press
charges against the indigenous leader
but amid an uproar backtracked seen as
another example of flip-flopping on the
part of the western hemisphere's
youngest president
this is a government of a young
generation of millennials and they're
learning to manage a complex state
apparatus in a country that's impatient
with many problems this is a year for
learning the ropes a year of transition
the hope is that bodhichu has been in
office for less than five months will
learn the ropes soon without losing the
confidence of those who elected him
every new president has to come face to
face with the reality that being in the
opposition is easier than being in
office president gabriel boric is
learning the hard way that reconciling
his convictions and his electoral
promises with the need to make pragmatic
decisions is a delicate juggling act
lucian newman al jazeera santiago